all right ricky
yeah ricky where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
i'm i'm originally from philly
philadelphia on the south side
and tell me about your family growing up
both mom and dad yeah well my father i
never knew him but my mother
she
she she tried to raise me but she she
was involved in a lot of a lot of heroin
use
and she had a lot of different
boyfriends
um
she had a boyfriend named paul
when i was when i was six years old
up until i was
eight and a half
that he he he would molest me
and
and um he always threatened me and told
him if i tell
that he he would beat me so i was always
scared to tell and then
he carried on
until i was like 14
and i ran away
i ran away
and i ended up a little bit in new york
and uh chicago but
i had i had a grandmother that lived in
los angeles and so i came to los angeles
and i started using crack cocaine
in
1983
and she found out and she kicked me out
and i had no place to go i was homeless
and i was still young in my early
twenties and
you know i i ended up on scare roll
i didn't i didn't know anything about
the skill roll
and i was like alone but
i fell in with the wrong crowd
and
i was manipulated
into
uh
giving
with basically just suck and dick
for for hits and stuff like that and i
wasn't making no money at it but i just
wanted to smoke
uh
and so
so
that became like a loss a little hustle
for me i guess but i was just sitting
around and i would wait
and i would do these things because you
know
i didn't have no no way to make money or
anything
and
um yeah are you gay or
are you gay or straight
well i i'm not i'm not gay like
but like
sometimes if if if i'm going to smoke
and then i'll just do what i have to do
but i'm i'm not like gay and say like i
would go to a party
and
and meet guys or anything like that it's
just that
i don't know else how else to get your
drugs
so
i'm not i'm not like gay like that but i
do have gay friends
and
you know
if i need money or something like that
i just i don't know i party
so
um i've been in prison
a few times
for
for
like uh you know
possession and stuff like that
and
and you know uh
i'm from back east and stuff like that
and the guys are here they really don't
like these the dudes from back east
i
i was raped in a county jail
i was raped in the county jail a few
times
and
you know it's not it's been a horrible
experience
um i was in and out of rehabs and stuff
like that
well i really i really wasn't going to
rehabs like for help or anything i was
actually was going to take a rest a
break from the streets
and i gave my little weight back or
whatever and i just go right back
out there and and just smoke and
and do whatever i have to do to get to
get the crack
so
i'm i'm in my 50s now
i try not to do the things that i was
doing when i was young but sometimes i
have no options
you know i don't i don't run out there
and want to hurt nobody or anything like
that
but
if this is just the way things go
sometime to me
the other night
i was
i was walking down the street
and i seen a bag on the street
and i picked it up and it had a whole
bunch of box in it
and i didn't think anybody seen me or
whatever
but the guy seen me
and he said i stole his stuff and i
wanted to give it back to him
but i wasn't trying to steal but i
didn't know it was his stash
and like what was in the bag
a bunch of rocks
probably like 40 or 50 rocks of crack
cocaine oh crack yeah
and
they beat me up and they they beat me up
pretty bad this time
and i got the bruises on my face and
stuff
and
the thing was
when they was kicking my ass
i seen a couple rocks fall on the ground
and i couldn't think of nothing else but
to pick them up
mom was getting my ass kicked
and
and i i i i held it the best i could
and
not when i went when i went to to go
smoking
i i didn't have my pipe
and it's just this guy he had a fight
and i didn't know that he he was a
rapist
and
he took me in his alley and he tried to
rape me and i was already beat up
but i just wanted to smoke and he he
beat me up a little bit
but i wouldn't i he didn't rape me he
didn't get he didn't get it not this
time
so i was pretty happy for that
but i'm i'm just trying to make it and
keep on going
and
do the best i can
oh
you've been living this life for how
long
i've been since you're a young teen
right since i was a young teen i've been
in i've been in this life
and now it's getting bad it was getting
bad i have a lot of
some friends that i do know
uh
i've been knowing them scared bro for
for quite some time
they um
they're dying they're dying because of
feeding off smoke yeah fentanyl looks
like crack yeah it looks like fracking
sometimes like
if the people if some people don't like
you
or or anything like that you may own
some money or something
then that seems like the kind of the
easiest way to commit a murder was
was just to give god fentanyl
and people are dying in and
i had got a hold of some fentanyl
and
and it it almost killed me
but i i had a friend that had narcan
and they brought me back and i refused
to ambulance
but i didn't feel too good so i try to
be cautious
about who i buy or smoke with now
because of the fitnah thing
it's like the number one killer out here
have you been married
uh no or i haven't been married
one guy
that he paid me a hundred dollars to
give him a blow job
and i did it
but he made a proposition because
he he wanted me he wanted me to
marry
this this guy
but he's from mexico
and they approve
in california same-sex marriage
and i try not i try not to be gay but it
seems like that
is always coming
come in some way around in my life
and and you know for money i sometimes i
just can't exist
so i i indulged in in the activities
but he was going he wanted to pay me to
marry a mexican guy because they could
stay here in the united states
but that's the closest to marriage i
haven't been
but i didn't do it you know a few
thousand dollars sounded good to me
but i didn't do it
so i i've been single most of my life
because of
the drugs and all the things that i did
i kind of
sometimes i don't feel ashamed and i'm i
smoke cocaine just the num the memories
and the pain
and it's a struggle
i'm still homeless
and
i'm i'm scared because of the culvert
19.
do you feel like
crack has kind of derailed your life
i wish i wish i wouldn't never took the
first hit
i don't know
if i could ever just stop
on my own
i would doubt it
um
yeah crack has to to
took over my life
and that's all i that's all i think
about
i i have been no job and i have no
savings
or even no credit good credit i got real
bad credit or anything so i don't know
what i'm gonna do
with the rest of my life except with
this smoke
crack
where do you where do you stay now
i stand on
on the street
called uh
series yeah a couple blocks that are you
in a tent yeah
you've been living in a tent for how
long
i've been in the intent since 1989.
uh i guess you could say off and on
because i have
done a few
prisons um
do you have any kids
no not that i know
i i really i really i have sex with
women anyway
so
yeah so
are your is your mom still alive
well my mom my mother died of an aids
virus in 1995
and i don't know who my dad is
yeah and so
um
i do have a
brother and sometimes whenever i have a
phone
i do call him
you know
he's about the only one
that i can communicate with
and everybody else i guess i kind of
shut them out because of my lifestyle
but what emotions do you go through do
you get
any emotions that come up from you
some sometimes i want to commit suicide
well
to be honest i had i had smoked some
fentanyl
in an attempt to kill myself
and it almost worked when someone gave
me some narcan
and brought me back and i tell them like
that wasn't part of the plan
but it was kind of scary you know
you know
yeah
but yeah i contemplate suicide because
my life's just all messed up
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing i've learned
in my life is
i guess never get yourself in something
that you can't get yourself out of
because i have found myself in
situations behind my addiction to crack
that
it was no way out of it unless it was a
body bag
so i just roll with the punches
so yeah i learned that lesson that i
would you know to never get myself in
something that i can't get out of
all right ricky thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
i wish you lots of luck out here
all right
thank you
you